No, no.
It was the craziest thing because...
The first idea was to do it in English,...
...and I thought that I could speak English with an accent.
I thought that I could do that.
I was super skinny.
Yeah.
I was 40 pounds lighter.
And I didn't speak a word of Spanish.
So, when they decided to do it, I was like, "These guys are crazy!"
What I did was I flew myself.
Netflix didn't even know I was being considered to play the part.
But I flew myself to Medellin, to Colombia, in order to learn Spanish.
And I booked myself in a university, in a Spanish course for foreigners.
So, I was in a classroom with Japanese teenagers and...
How crazy is that?
And how much weight did you gain?
40 pounds.
Wow!
Yeah.
So, it's like being in school, learning things and eating delicious...
...freshman ice cream, yeah.